The objective is clear:...
...prioritize the elderly and those most at risk from COVID-19.
That was the message delivered from France's national health authority...
...as it laid out a comprehensive vaccine rollout strategy...
...comprised of five specific phases.
As soon as the first batch of vaccines arrive in the country,...
...phase one of the rollout will see them set aside...
...for over 650,000 elderly residents in France's nursing homes.
Phase 2 will then see a mass expansion,...
...first to reach people over the age of 75,...
...then to people age 65 and up suffering with comorbidities...
...and finally to all people between 65 and 74.
The third phase follows in a similar pattern.
People over the age of 50 will receive the vaccine...
...followed by those under 50 suffering with comorbidities.
Then in phase 4, people who have been in high risk contact with coronavirus cases...
...and who have never previously received vaccines will be prioritized.
And in the 5th and final phase of the rollout,...
...all people 18 and up who don't currently suffer from comorbidities...
...will be able to receive vaccines.
Millions of vaccines are currently in transit to the European Union,...
...of which France is set to receive about 15%...
...with the end of 2020 and beginning of 2021 currently being earmarked.
However, French authorities will have to do more to persuade locals.
Recent surveys by France's Institute of Public Opinion...
...show more than 59% of French don't intend to take COVID vaccines,...
...which will not be made compulsory by government.